jury duty serving as a juror is one of
the most important responsibilities you
have as a citizen of this country we
think we know how it works twelve people
sit on a jury to hear case and they go
into a separate room to deliberate and
they only come back once they have a
unanimous decision the vote must be
unanimous a unanimous vote a jury's
decision must be unanimous but in two
states in America juries don't need
unanimous decisions in most felony cases
these in an Oregon of what we call
non-unanimous juries when criminal
trials only ten of the twelve jurors
need to agree this is an important
moment the way we think the justice
system works isn't always how it works
I'm Dre McKesson and this is truth be
told it wasn't always this way Louisiana
back when the Louisiana territory became
a part of the United States in 1803 the
law required unanimous verdicts to
convict those charged with crimes
however this was overturned by
legislative act in 1880 and when the
state constitution was written in 1889
it allowed juries to convict people
without a unanimous decision and this
came right after reconstruction and so
kind of putting it in its historical
context we understand why so many of our
other states have kind of moved past
this but we're still kind of holding
onto this at the same Constitutional
Convention the motives of lawmakers are
made pretty clear one declare that they
were there to quote establish the
supremacy of the white race like he
literally said that non-unanimous juries
help do just that they essentially
prevented black jurors from stopping
convictions of black defendants the
vestiges of these old racist impulses
persists today and the impact on
conviction rates in Louisiana is
unmistakable the New Orleans advocate
recently found jury voting records for
993 convictions over six years in 402 of
these cases there were non unanimous
decisions and in these cases even though
there might have been wanted to hold out
jurors there mustn't matter
the idea of the holdout juror might be
super common in American pop culture you
know the juror who can't be swayed the
they make movies about Oh there's always
love not guilty
well in Louisiana they often get ignored
these non unanimous decisions are more
likely to effect a year-long
investigation by The Advocate found
conclusively that Louisiana's
non-unanimous jury law
disproportionately punishes black
defendants the percentage of trial
convictions with holdout juries is 43
percent for black defendants compared to
33 percent for white defendants there
has recently been a public outcry
against these non-unanimous story
decisions and this has resulted in a
push towards reform there's a bill
making its way through the legislature
seeking to change a law many call
problematic a vote on the amendment to
the state constitution requiring all
juries handing down guilty verdicts to
be unanimous is on the ballot this fall
in Louisiana but there's some Louisiana
District Attorney's still opposing this
attitude shows how pervasive the idea is
that even though this Constitution was
created to literally uphold and codify
white supremacy it's somehow no longer
racist today voters in Louisiana have
the power to change it this fall
Oregon has a similar story to Louisiana
I'd like to welcome you as a juror in
the Oregon Court system in 1933 after
jury failed the convicted Jewish man of
murdering a Protestant man a local paper
connected the supposedly unjust ruling
to the ignorance of immigrants they
called the immigrants untrained in the
American jury system these
anti-immigrant views were widespread and
the very next year Oregon voters amended
the state constitution to allow non
unanimous juries to hand down guilty
verdicts in most criminal cases in this
law is still on the books and just like
in Louisiana it disappoints the affects
people of color look at the 2016 case of
olan Williams he was convicted even
though two men
a visionary voted to acquit him he
appealed to a higher court on the basis
of his conviction was non unanimous and
made by jury consisting of only one
lecture the two jurors one black and one
white who voted not guilty in the end
had no say in the verdict one of the
jurors said if two people don't believe
a person is guilty there has to be some
level of doubt and that's a big part of
the problem the whole point of a
unanimous decision is to overcome the
differences of opinion and to reach a
consensus 48 of the 50 states operate
this way Oregon's non-unanimous story
system doesn't have to be like this the
Oregon State Constitution can be changed
too in this practice the problem goes
beyond how we count votes on juries it
extends to how we put people on them in
the first place the black people it can
be difficult to get on a jury at the
beginning of many cases lawyers can
strike jurors from the trial in some
cases the people they strike happen to
be people of color but this is against
the law according to 1986 Supreme Court
ruling Batson V Kentucky the Batson
decision stated the prosecutor should be
able to provide racially neutral reasons
for moving people from the juries
basically lawyers can't specifically
list race as a reason to remove a juror
but racially neutral reasons can just be
another loophole for lawyers to exploit
one study in to jury selection found a
series of ridiculous ways Laura seemed
to have used to get around the Batson
ruling he looked like a drug dealer he
shucked and jived
as he walked having dyed red hair
wearing a large white hat and sunglasses
the jury researchers consistently find
that people of color underrepresented on
juries this isn't just about Louisiana
in Oregon this is about a system that
effectively keeps certain people off of
juries we take for granted the idea that
will be tried under a jury of our peers
but that is just not the case for so
many Americans
Oh